this
is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice chrissy
wright ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we take your questions about your
life and your money it's a free call at
triple eight
eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five stephen in fort lauderdale
florida starts off
this hour hey stephen what's up hey
david
how are you doing better than i deserve
sir how can we help
thank you um i am 21 years old
and i have about 20 thousand dollars in
cash that i saved up
i'm going to be going off to college in
the fall and
um i'm planning on buying real estate
about a three bed
bedroom home that i can rent out the
room and help me pay my mortgage
so i don't have to pay rent when i go up
to college
i also have about a four thousand dollar
car loan that i have yet to pay off
um and my uncle has been advising me to
to buy a house but my mom is kind of
like hesitant about me doing it
so i just like to get your advice
well i love real estate and i love your
uh the fact that you're putting some
thought into this i like all of that
i think it's uh uh you know good on your
part where'd you get 20
000 at 21 years old way to go
uh well i was a general manager for a uh
for a qsr restaurant
making pizzas and i did that for about a
year
and i was fortunate enough to give up
good money while i was living with my
mom and i still
am actually right now okay so where are
you going to college
i'm going to orlando at ucf good for you
it's a great school
i went there for a year and a half
that's awesome
it's it's the largest school in america
right now and it's a great school we've
done events there on campus and gotten
to know a lot of their administration
there
it's a solid solid choice okay well um
while i love real estate um
i would advise you against your plan i'm
not sure i can talk you out of it
but here is the downsides of your plan
you are trying to go to school and learn
and graduate the distraction of running
a business dealing with freaking
roommates
could really be devastating it sounds
like it's like it sounds like a hot
knife through butter and it's not
you're going to deal with so much
freaking drama over this four years
with roommates and collecting rent and
whose ketchup that is in the
refrigerator and all this other bs
that you're going to get distracted from
your studies
and you're worried about real estate
instead of being worried about getting
your degree
you have one freaking job for the next
four years and that's
graduate on time with your degree
with no debt and i would use the twenty
thousand dollars towards
that end uh and i would be a renter
and i would have very little going on in
my life except going to school
and graduating on time or early
this is such a transitional time in your
life too stephen while that seems like a
great idea right now and like dave said
i don't think it's a
a bad idea in general i think it's just
a bad idea right now
because you have no idea what the next
three years holds you have no idea what
type of expenses you're going to have
you need to pay off that debt with some
of the money that you have
keep saving up cash flow your way
through college and then
when you're out of college you know you
want to put down routes there you know
where you want to be all that good stuff
you have your degree behind you
some more money in the bank three to six
months of expenses you're debt-free
then save up and put that money down on
a house i'll give you an example dave i
went to ucf for a year and a half
and i loved it but i realized after
living there a year and a half i didn't
want to
put down roots there i didn't want to
get married get a job live there forever
i wanted to go back to tennessee
and so i decided to transfer to ut
knoxville to get in-state tuition to
save my mom the money
since i wasn't going to live there
forever but when i went as a freshman i
didn't know that
and you just don't know a lot of 18. you
think you know but you're going to learn
a lot about yourself
your dreams your plans in the next four
years and so save that money before you
make any
long-term commitments like that
especially with the cash that you have
and then after college makes some of
those decisions so
i'll even one-up that that's i i
went to school to get a degree in
finance and real estate
i was selling real estate for a living
while i was in school
i love real estate i almost bought a
home in
maryville tennessee outside of knoxville
i was going to university of tennessee
a little cheap but little nothing house
because i didn't
because i wanted to be a real estate
investor like you do
and uh if i had done that when sharon
and i got married
and decided to move across the state
after graduation
we would have been stuck with this
stinky butt little house in maryville
tennessee
and it would have been an anchor to our
plans instead of a blessing yeah
and that's what christie's referring to
with this level of transition in your
life so
it's a good idea at the wrong time which
makes it a bad idea
for all of those reasons please don't do
it please take four thousand dollars and
pay off your car today
bank the rest of it and invest in the
highest possible investment on the
planet
his name is matt invest in yourself
making sure you
graduate debt-free steve stevenson yep
his name is investing
matt or steven but want to make sure
steven knows we're talking
stephen's like who's matt i miss that
what's the next call that's up and
that's how it shows
how about this show really i want
stephen to make sure
he knew we were talking to him thank you
thank you yeah
oh that was bad okay i don't know i
don't know how you recover from that one
we go to matt that's how we recover
and that's next hey matt steven's going
to be investing in you i hope you like
that what's up man that sounds good to
me
so what's up how can we help so i
i have a general question related to
functioning um i always have an argument
with my wife
exactly how much we're able to spend on
you know
things to enjoy our lives like vacations
and like uh
you know i like to golf and i like to
you know i'm more of a spender um like
going out to eat things like that
so we're pretty well off are you out of
debt
i know that yeah okay and you have an
emergency fund
yeah and what's your household income
uh maybe about like 220 to 230.
and what are you wanting to budget for
entertainment and golf and what is she
saying
she wants to so i guess
uh i mean it kind of varies obviously i
don't golfing
okay there's your problem you're making
this crap up as you go you're not
agreeing to anything and she sees this
as an infinite bottomless pit
you just want to spend what you want
when you want to right yeah
i mean basically can't be a child you
have to put it on paper
i don't care what the amount is but you
got to put it on paper the fact that
you're not willing to put a number down
and stick to it
that's what's scaring her it's not the
number it's scaring me too by the way
steven too because he's investing in you
yeah i i mean again we i'm not like you
know irrational about it but like yeah
i think i guess you're right yeah you
are because you're not willing to put a
limit on it you're not in congress you
have to put a limit on it you feel you
feel like a budget is restrictive
yes or no i don't know i mean a little
bit considering that you know again i
i don't you know the way i feel i spend
my money i don't overdo it but i guess
dave's right all you gotta do is put a
number on it you see the plan
you might be surprised that what she
would agree to in the in terms of the
number if you put a number to it
and you agree that there is a point at
which you look at yourself in the mirror
and you say no
enough already this month we're limiting
this i don't care what the number is
i really don't as long as you're not
going into debt to do it
you just but you can't just be going
i'll just be okay
i'll out or no no you have to have a
number then we're both in agreement
you'll be fine
that's all you got to do to fix this
it's not how much you're spending
is the fact that you're not willing to
put any limit on it at all
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the air open
phones at
eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about
your life and your money miles is with
us miles is
in wichita kansas hey miles how can we
help
hi mr ramsey it's honor and pleasure to
speak with you today
you too what's up well
uh i would like some advice from you on
uh some purchase opportunities that i've
got
to buy at home and
with some aspects to my life i'm
wondering if i should
pay cash for it or if i should try and
get a mortgage or
or get a loan
i've i pretty much got the cash to pay
for it but as a christian i'm wondering
if
i should because i've got the chance to
do that if i should go and do it or
because of the convenience if i should
just go ahead and
get a mortgage on it um
i'm the the biggest stickler to my
life aspect is i'm 20 years old and
i'm going to school part-time i work
full-time with my dad and i've got two
or three businesses besides that
and i'm wondering is is freeing up
uh some of the cash for capital for what
i do smart or should i try and
um to keep it um available
for my businesses or should i just put
all of that capital
into that house and and keep it there
and then just slowly
so much money do you have saved
uh right around 100 000 and you're 20
years old
yes sir how'd you do that
i worked hard i've been extremely
blessed
my parents are very wise
in raising me in a way to be debt-free
work hard
i took your uh ramsey
course through high school and just as a
general
attitude to life um you know knowing
everything is god's and knowing
everything that
um i've got is not mine and just
managing it as well as just
keeping my expenses low and saving where
i can you're amazing
that's incredible so what uh uh
what kind of income are you earning a
year between all these things you're
doing
so i don't specifically have a lot of
income um like i said i work with my dad
full time
my first real every year of work and
income that i got from him was pretty
much just last year year and a half i
took home about 30 000
and then probably between all the other
stuff i do it's running ten thousand
dollars
um so where did 100 come from again
just pretty much that doesn't get to 100
pretty much just saving i mean ever
since ever since i've been young
um i i mow lawns i've been doing that
since i was 12 or 13.
um you know like i said just being very
blessed and just
i don't spend a lot of money do you live
with your mom and dad still
yes i do and that's that's another um
aspect of it
uh as 20 as i'm 20 years old i'm going
to school part-time as well
so i'm i'm looking to buy this house as
a rental
and then when i graduate in a couple
years uh try and try and move into it as
my own house
no i would not buy a house
you think that's the wise place to be i
think the wise thing to do is for you to
finish school
before you worry before you i would not
get in the rental business this is the
don't get in the rental business while
you're in college female yeah
so we didn't know it was but it is
yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't put you in
the rental business while you're making
30 000
a year and trying to go through school
uh i don't mind you getting there
and you are you are an overachiever
you're an incredible young man
but let's not uh get confused about what
got us here it wasn't real estate
i love real estate and i want you to own
some real estate someday
i thought you were buying this house to
move into so
that that you know might have changed
the answer but i don't think it does
um i think you're going to continue to
pile up money and you go ahead and get
in school
and get your button gear and get
finished and when you graduate and you
leave
home and you start your own life and you
have a pile of cash pay cash for your
first home that you're going to live in
then start talking about buying rental
property that you pay cash for
but i wouldn't get this out of order i
wouldn't get it backwards it's so
tempting too i'm sure miles because you
have this pile of cash
you have a hundred thousand dollars so
you could rationalize in your head well
i have this money so i should
buy a house you're living at home you're
fine finish out school just because you
have the money doesn't mean you have to
spend it
just like we were saying earlier you're
in a transitional time in your life
what you need today is not necessarily
what you'll need or want in a year
or three years finish out school and
then make a decision
about your housing situation and your
money
yeah so with rare exceptions
if you never buy a piece of real estate
before you're 25 years old
it's not the end of the world including
your home
yeah i mean you can just move out and
rent
a little apartment and get your life
started yeah this idea that you have to
move out
into a furnished home with a skylight
and a jacuzzi
um at 24 years old or 23 years old is
just
guys there's it's not talking down to
you because you're young
all i'm saying is just have a little
freaking patience well and one of the
things i heard the most out of college
dave and
i've heard it a million times is you're
throwing money away on rent you're
throwing money away on rent you hear it
again again
that is an oversimplified statement on
the situation what you're buying
is time peace of mind someone else is
dealing with all the maintenance of the
home there's so much more that goes into
home ownership than just
the purchase price of the house and i
think a lot of young people don't
consider that they don't think about
a new ac unit or you need a new roof or
something goes wrong
and all the headache that goes with it
whether you're living in it or not
that being a renter for 15 or 20 years
is a bad idea
being a renter for 36 months while
you're going through some transitional
periods in your life
like leaving home for the first time
those kinds of things it's not dumb at
all yeah
it's not dumb at all renters don't go to
hell it's not a salvation issue
okay i mean you're not like done
something completely stupid where you've
ruined your whole life
because you're a renter for a little
while i've rented
you know and i own a bunch of real
estate and i believe in real estate and
i want you to get some real estate
but real estate purchases as an
investment is
very unwise and will set you back
in your whole wealth building process it
will set you back
not push you forward if you do it before
you've done some of these other things
and so it is a late in the game late in
the baby steps
idea that you invest in real estate
because otherwise real estate will kick
you in the teeth and will move you
backwards
in your wealth building and so no you
don't need to buy a rental house when
you don't have a house
that's paid for that you live in no you
don't need to buy a rental house
until you have graduated from college no
you don't need to buy a rental house
until you can pay cash for it
no you don't need to buy a rental house
until you're out of debt how own a home
have an emergency fund in place and it
paid off your home
no you don't need to buy a rental house
before you're 25
unless you're in a very very unusual
situation
now this young man here is pretty
incredible he's done some really cool
stuff
but here's the thing dude you buy a
house right now with all that money and
you're not making but 30 grand
you don't have any money you gave up all
your money because
i thought you were going to tell me in
this business you're making a hundred
thousand dollars a year or something i
didn't know where this money
but this has been from 12 years old he
saved everything start cutting money
and that's how you got here so you're a
tremendous saver you are not yet
a tremendous earner you will be
i think just listening to you i think
you're incredible i think you're going
to be a big place when you're but when
you're making 60 or 80
000 or 180 000 it makes the this
equation completely different
and that's where you're going to be when
you graduate with your four-year degree
and you have your full-on career
and you're doing stuff because you're a
dude that gets stuff done yeah but just
be it's okay
just take just breathe just breathe you
you're you're not gonna
you're not you're not gonna die you're
not you're not stupid you're not um
throwing money away to rent
for 36 months from your 22nd birthday to
your 25th birthday it's not it's just
not the end of the freaking world
and that includes those of you getting
married and she wants to buy a house or
he wants to buy a
i don't give a crap you're broke when
broke people buy houses you get
broker and that's why they call them
real estate brokers that's where that
comes from
so and i've done that and lots of people
have done that and we've seen the strain
and the coaching over the years
you know we you and i have both seen it
yeah over and over and over again yep
this is the ramsey shack
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt
free stage michael and angela are with
us hey guys how are you
good great awesome to have you so here
to do a debt-free scream where do you
live
uh fairville minnesota just south of the
twin cities bowling hour
okay very cool good good for you guys
well welcome how much debt did you pay
off
thirteen thousand two hundred eighty
five dollars
and six cents how long did this take
about 40 months whoa and your range of
income during that time
we started at 90 000
all the way up to 230.
good for you what do you guys do for a
living i'm an optometrist
and i do agricultural research very good
so what kind of debt was this 313
thousand well we had uh 300
in a bed um 30 000 between two vehicles
and the rest was sallie mae lotsa sally
may
sally may did a number on y'all yeah a
big one wow
so tell us the story what happened it
was
a few months after our daughter was our
first daughter was born
we were sitting there and
we were talking about you know
retirement
and paying off these loans early and
saving for college for our
our daughter and i said to michael this
is overwhelming
we can't do it all and we were going 10
different directions
everywhere there wasn't a plan and then
i remember my best friend
in college her dad um had mentioned a
book
the total money makeover yeah so i
caught i called her and said
you know what's this book we read it i
was on board right away
i thought there were a lot of great
ideas in the book
and that we you know we could use some
of these principles and it might really
help us
and then we had our first budget meeting
and
there was some things going on with the
job and we wrote everything down and we
realized
there's a lot of debt that was the first
time we put all the debt on paper
and it was terrifying terrifying
terrifying
basically we realized we were coming up
800 bucks short
every month just on debt that wasn't
even
whoa that wasn't even groceries
groceries
what'd you do how'd you get that fixed
we moved yep found it sold your house
well we
we moved down so we found a new job
opportunity
so basically angie was able to get a job
where she was making the same where
we both were and we just we went and
then
i was able to find a job and then from
there
angie was able to pick up more jobs
extra jobs
game on wow so you kicked you that's
what kept this income
you tripled almost your income yeah yeah
we at one point i think we were
um i don't think i had a day off
in a couple months yeah yeah
every day every day every day but yep
that's that's when the snowball
really really rocked yeah yeah yeah
the problem is you work all the time the
good news is you make a lot of money
you're darn right
you can clean up a mess pretty quick if
you get bigger shovels yeah and then you
don't have to do it forever it's just a
part-time thing
i mean it's a temporary process uh to do
that to work like that but you were
working like maniacs
yes yeah yeah i mean you can only tweak
the budget so much you know we
we we were able to get everything out of
the budget we could at that point you
got to up the income
yeah did you sell the cars or keep them
we kept them okay worked your way
through it okay
very cool so this really came down to
moving to a different city
and changing your income potential and
then stepping into that potential yep
yep
okay two and a half long
years it's three and a half three and a
half oh no
we wish i headed it up he's like this
guy can't do me
the whole dividing by 12 things are
probably yeah oh my gosh that's
incredible
so i'm quite i'm curious because i know
a lot of people
are scared of that moment you just
described when you wrote it all down
they don't want to face it because it is
scary right like i think you said it was
terrifying
when you first faced it we were
blissfully unaware we had no idea
right how many people are fully unaware
that is a great phrase
how many people are listening right now
that are blissfully unaware and they're
scared to face it what would you say to
them on this side now
having faced it been terrified busted
your behinds to get out of it and now
you're debt-free speak to that person
that doesn't want to write it down that
doesn't want to face it
you can do it you can do it you can do
it we
we had a gold chart from you know zero
up to our
300 000 um debt load
and it seems overwhelming
but you can do it you can't we i mean
when we found this plan
this is the greatest thing everyone
needs to do this why isn't everyone
doing this
and then we try to explain to people and
they're just like oh you know that we
can't do that
or or you know it works for you you know
you guys make a lot of money and
i mean that's why we wanted to come here
like you can do it yeah we can do it
you can do it you can do it go to work
go to work
a great place to go when you're broke
yeah that would that quote went in my
head almost every year
literally maniacs this is impressive
very impressive
so how old are you i'm 34.
32. okay and you paid off
313 000 in 40 months
and you're done how's it feel liberating
just we're free we're free it's
different going to work that first day
after i paid at office
you know i i'm going to work because i
want to yeah
it's totally changed the way i am at
work and
it's awesome yep me too you get your
hours back to a normal ground now angela
yes not a saturday or sunday ever again
yeah
never again if you work like no one else
later you can work like no one else if
you live like no one else later you can
live and give like no one else that's
right
you guys are incredible so it was worth
it
absolutely 100 what do you tell people
the key to getting out of that is
i would say the biggest thing getting on
board
with each other um writing everything
down that was huge for us
the budget i mean we every month
we were going through that and the
biggest thing for us
i would say is you have to stay
motivated three and a half years is a
long time
is a very long time and we
we had like i said our big gold chart
and
every 10 michael and i we would go out
on a date
night and then every time
every month when we paid off things we
would have a dream meeting
and we'd say why are we doing this you
know what are our future goals and
basically
that was our motivation yeah you know
you'd fill in the chart and it's like
okay
that's another two percent you know here
we go you can see the progress
and that was probably i mean one of the
hardest things is because
when you have that much debt you know
one percent is
three grand yeah that's a lot of money
money yeah
and yeah those those i would say are the
biggest things
yeah that's powerful yeah i love that
you guys did that i love that you
celebrated those mile markers because
y'all's
every most people getting out of debt is
a marathon y'all's really was a marathon
i mean three and a half years a long
time that's a lot of money
but to see that progress and celebrate
that progress it probably motivated you
okay let's get the next thirty thousand
let's get the next you know ten percent
whatever that was and
and you stuck with it because of that
well done and it was tough too because
we
we had consolidated all the loans so it
was
it was one payment it was we weren't
knocking little loans off as we went so
so that motivation was it was key yeah
yeah very cool you guys well done well
done well done very proud of you very
proud of you we got a copy of rachel
cruz's latest
new york times bestseller know yourself
know your money as a gift
we appreciate you coming all the way
down from minnesota to
to do your debt free scream and share
your story it's inspiring what you've
done you're rock stars
very very well done you're free you did
it
michael and angela from minnesota 313
000
paid off in 40 months making 90 to 230
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one we're dead
[Applause]
well done you guys very well done that's
awesome
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
christy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today our famous 10
sale is back which means you can get her
number one best-selling book business
boutique for ten dollars you can get the
total money makeover the proximity
principle and most of our best-selling
books are on sale for ten
dollars each about a sixty percent
saving on over
40 best-selling books pretty cool
go to ramseysolutions.com
store ramseysolutions.com check out the
10
sale and there's more we've got a gift
for you
you can enter to win our ramsey cash
giveaway we're giving away 500
cash every week starting this week
plus a grand prize of 5 000 cash
you can enter daily for extra chances to
win no purchase necessary got to be 18
or older to win
text the word cash to 33
789 and you can enter now text
cash to 33 789 again that 10
sale is all going on at
ramseysolutions.com
store ken is in los
angeles hi ken welcome to the ramsey
show
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help
well i'm a bit nervous i'll just do my
best to ask the question
and hopefully get some good life and
financial advice from you
okay um i've been working for myself for
almost 20 years
um in the financial services industry
my income over the last few years has
done real well
except for the last maybe year or so
it's been declining
in part because of the company i work
for
and represent um
is is uh is not doing super great
uh so i've been working really hard to
pay off the house uh early we're not in
any debt whatsoever
um other than our our mortgage and
uh we're at a we're at a crossroads my
wife and i and our family as to
whether we should potentially leave
leave los angeles leave california
and move out of state to to an area
that's obviously less
expensive to accelerate our
my financial goals and you know my
wife's financial goals i guess as well
even though we're not
always on the on the same page but um or
just to stick it out here and
essentially use the money that i've
saved uh to pay the house off that
we're almost right there to pay the
house off um
and instead of paying the house off use
the money to try and stimulate some
some income in other ways uh
entrepreneurial ways or something how
much money you got saved
about 320 grand way to go okay
so the only reason i use the phrase in
my life
stick it out is there has to be a prize
on the other side of sticking it out
what's the prize on the other side of
sticking it out in los angeles it sounds
like you're just
gonna endure to the end of your life and
then you die
you know it's a good question um you
know i mean if if we were sitting down
with my wife
uh and you um we we would both admit to
to ourselves that
more than likely california is not not
our future
even though this is where we grew up
this is our home obviously there's
the list is really long as to the
reasons why to leave
um you occasionally allude to them on
on on your program but uh but no i mean
our kids are
our oldest is in high school um and uh
and we do
really enjoy the area that we're in he's
got a good set of friends which is
really important
i think you know good social support
group so
as far as sticking it out what i mean by
that is like you know for the next
few years or so while uh
our oldest get through high school and
then more unlikely we would be
probably exiting okay all right
and so your oldest is what you're in
high school he's a sophomore
okay so you either leave now or you
leave
in two years uh
uh more like four to five one you got a
middle schooler
oh you're going to run that haul up now
that's about that's about to get through
about to go into high school yeah yeah
i'm curious about something you said a
second ago you said my financial goals
and i guess my wife's financial goals
but you said it separately like y'all
are on the same page what are some of
these conversations
i mean about it yeah so um
complicated but i mean um it's uh
we're not we're not 100 percent on you
know i've been listening to
dave your show for four years um
ever since i decided i need to make some
some lifestyle changes
my wife generally speaking is very
supportive of of
things we do we have a great marriage um
however at the same time
she looks at our situation is like
you know very unique meaning you know
able to pay a house off
an expensive house in los angeles uh at
in in the early 40s very blessed and
you know she would she misses and i and
i do want to support her i mean we
i've we've sacrificed a lot you know
seeing friends take vacations
yeah um we're not you know um our kids
are getting older and she's
it's getting a little bit uh challenging
for her to
continue to i i would say live health
poor
to some degree i think that you guys
have been on
a financial planner tightwad budget and
she's over it
yeah yeah you could say that
okay and i am too to be honest but
here's the thing
here's the thing the offset of the kids
being moved
is that your quality of life on a daily
basis and an annual basis is going to
increase considerably
yeah in other words the kids are going
to go on vacation the kids are
not going to be seeing mom and dad dad
particularly who's pretty much
miserable there uh and and all through
my high school years all i remember was
my dad was miserable
yeah i'm out of there dude
yeah just based on what you're telling
me and i think the impact and i would
move tomorrow
i think the impact on your kid resetting
some friends
kids do it all the time i mean there's
lots of people who move with a kid in
high school
and they survive and uh you know
is it ideal no it's not ideal but
is there a good set of friends with the
proper value systems that you get
plugged into
in a city that is uh where you can
explore your career options
your wife can be allowed to go on
vacation you guys have got a little
wiggle room in your budget to go out and
do some things that you've not been
doing lifestyle-wise
and you pay cash for a house with 300
000 bucks when you make the move and you
start a new career
it's a new adventure for everyone and
everyone's getting an upgrade in this
model
uh except the kid is getting a bit of a
down
but overall the kids getting an upgrade
yeah and they may not understand it
first they probably won't but you're
their parent you get to make the
decisions for what's best for the family
and if this is what you and your wife
decide is best for your family you're
putting all of these right
in their life at risk or something be
different you're just changing high
school yeah
i mean i'm sorry i'm old you are it's
not it's not
get over it i'm you know you'll be all
right
you're gonna make it they will and when
they're on the other side of it
they will get to experience that they
just can't see past friday
night right now they're they're
teenagers that's how teenagers think and
act
they'll they'll be glad on the other
side of it and there'll be some whining
and gnashing of things
you know that'll be there but but i'm
telling you i think the quality of your
family unit i think dr john baloney
would tell us
that the vibe in your house your kids
pick up on the vibe
yeah it'll be overall worth pick up on
the stress that's in the air
they pick up on the disappointment
that's in the air the gritted teeth i'm
gonna
stick it out that's in the air that's
right and so i wouldn't stick it out
yeah it's done you and your wife are
both done but for different reasons
the only thing holding you there is a
sophomore in high school
sophomore in high school gets to go
along on this adventure
that's that's the way it is this is the
ramses we're going to explain it to them
yeah
and um but i mean i'm not being mean or
uncaring
you could certainly you can we can
empathize with a young person's feelings
that's not the point
we don't have to be mean about it or
just act like it doesn't matter it does
matter but their upgrade if they turn
their attitudes about this in the right
direction it's going to
far i mean they're going to parents who
aren't stressed parents who are living
the dream
lifestyle increases uh you know a
different environment
yeah to live in and and i it could be an
adventure
yeah and i think when you're when you're
in the weeds of decisions like that
sometimes it can be so hard to sort
through your options and all the
different variables but even like you
said
which is more important that you keep
the software in high school the middle
school or through the school system or
that you're happy and enjoying every
aspect of your life it sounds like five
years of hell
yeah it's like this is gonna affect
everything when you look at it like that
you go oh
and the only benefit is the kid doesn't
change friendships right
that's the only thing we're going
through five years of hell so a middle
schooler doesn't change
friend sets i'm just i'm done with this
no i wouldn't do it
i wouldn't do it i'm sorry hey man i
appreciate you it's
you got a good heart and you're thinking
this through you wanted some input
you got it and it's probably worth what
you paid for it this
is the ramsey show
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions
broadcasting from the dollar car rental
studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i am dave ramsey your host you jump in
we'll talk about your life
and your money open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five christy wright ramsey
personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today
again the number triple eight eight two
five five two two
five johnny is with us in fort bragg
north carolina hi
johnny how are you hi dave how are you
doing
better than i deserve sir how can we
help
good hey i was calling i have a couple
questions the first one
is if i have a loan with an interest
rate of less than one percent
why does it make sense to attack that
loan
and and try to get rid of that debt when
i could
use the minimum payments and not have to
pay a lot of interest
and put the extra money from my income
into a
savings account with a higher return or
a
uh roth ira or some sort of
retirement plan where i'm going to be
getting you know 10
return or higher if i was doing like
investing and stuff
okay and so how old are you
i'm 28 and a little bit of my background
um
i went to the i went to the united
states military academy
i got kicked out and luckily didn't have
to pay back everything
and i enlisted um but i still have that
loan payment so i'm
my income is around 2100 a month
and uh my loan my minimum
loan payments is 618 dollars and it was
originally 36 000
loan i got it down to about
10 five so good for you 10 500 good for
you
okay well it's it's a really good
question and it's asked by a lot of
people
and it took me a little while to
understand the answer
when i went broke and lost everything
because i had too much debt
my first part of my journey was through
a faith lens
because i had uh all these letters and
licenses and degrees after my name
all about finances said i was supposed
to know something about money but there
i was bankrupt
so apparently i was a doofus right and
so
i started approaching things first
through the faith lens and i read in the
bible that the borrower is slave to the
lender
and i started learning from christian
teachers that the bible doesn't have
anything good to say about debt so if
god doesn't like debt
why would i okay so i quit i don't
borrow money and i i
and i did it on that basis alone over
the years that was 30 years ago
over the years i also have approached it
through the lens of mathematics or
academia
and so here's what i have discovered
when you say all right i could invest in
a mutual fund at 12
why would i ever pay off my house at
three percent
because i could use that money and
invest it at 12 or 11 or whatever and
i'm gonna make an eight or a nine
percent spread and that's the essence of
your question isn't it
yeah i guess you know talking about a
house or something
or whatever whatever whatever whatever
the debt anytime i can borrow money at a
cheaper rate then i can invest it why
would i ever
not do that as much as i can do it
okay yeah and the way the way to explore
that and answer that
sometimes is scale something and see if
your idea works with scale
and so if you could borrow 50 million
dollars and go in debt 50 million
dollars
in order to invest that money and make
the spread would you do it and it kind
of that causes you to heart to stop a
second you go
get a little little tightness in your
throat and your stomach
if you're if you're mature anyway your
stomach starts to move up towards your
throat you think you want to throw up
when i put scale to the idea it scares
you
why does it scare you because there's
risk
and risk was left out of your formula
okay right so the honest truth is
there's actual mathematical ways to
insert risk into the formula
let me give you a little lesson here on
mutual funds okay
an aggressive growth stock mutual fund
is very volatile if you were to map it
it goes way up and way down like a super
crazy roller coaster
the difference in the top of that
mountain and the bottom of that valley
mathematically
in a statistical measure is called a
beta
the greater the beta the greater the
volatility the greater the risk
of the mutual fund and so if you have an
aggressive growth stock mutual fund
with a beta of two which will take your
breath away
or you have an uh and it makes a 26
rate of return you do not compare that
if you are sophisticated
apples to apples with a growth in income
mutual fund which has a beta of a 0.5
meaning the kitty roller coaster okay
right and so you don't compare 26
percent with 12 percent
without adjusting for risk and you use
an inverse formula in mathematics with
that beta
and adjust for risk and then you can
measure these things accurately against
each other risk adjusted
you have no risk adjustment in your
formula so your formula is wrong
right i understand that okay so don't
borrow money
because you're not risk adjusting on
your theoretical concept
and you're making twenty two hundred
dollars or twenty one hundred dollars a
month
and the second piece of data that you
wanna do is the study that we did here
and as we studied millionaires christie
and we stayed 10
167 millionaires we did not find
any of them that said the way i became a
millionaire
was by not paying off low interest debt
and investing the money yeah
not a single one yeah out of 10
167 that we interviewed and they were
ramsey millionaires and
white space millionaires meaning they
don't even know who i am or we are
and so if real millionaires aren't
doing that to become wealthy and your
formula is wrong
both of those things tell you don't do
this crap
yeah i think people get caught up in the
math and it's not that the math is not
important
enough in the math the the it's about
the motivation the momentum
of one thing at a time in the baby steps
but the thing i want you to account for
and you talked about this with risk dave
the thing that i think people miss is in
debt any type of debt with the risk
you're losing power and control and
options
when you own things when you save and
put your money in savings when you are
debt-free
then you have more power more control
and more options and everything we teach
is about increasing your power and
control and decreasing your risk
because when you do you increase your
probability of becoming wealthy
yes and you don't have to start over
again like i did because i was stupid
and deeply in debt
right and so you owe anyone anything you
know i never my risk meter was broken i
think when they get you in the real
estate business they take a hammer to
your risk meter and just break it
because all these real estate investors
they don't even they do not perceive the
risk of the leverage
yeah and they just buy you know we had
all these seminars going on in the 80s
nothing down real estate the guy went
chapter 11 that wrote the book you know
yeah and so um you know and all these
uh i was surrendering to a guy that i
had forgotten the name
there was a uh nothing down seminar on
tv on
the first infomercial was a guy named
dave del dotto okay
and i i ran into him at this bit he owns
a big house in cabo when i was visiting
down there the other day
and it's like he and he has a big winery
and all this stuff but he made all this
money from the infomercial
not from real estate so
yeah don't i mean real estate's fine but
here's the thing
debt is not the shortest path
to wealth because of the risk factor
that's what it comes down to johnny you
can try it and be a hard head if you
want
but that's the answer to the question
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
if you're feeling stuck or disengaged in
your current job
or maybe you just dread getting out of
bed to go to work in the morning
if you're searching for a new job for
any reason
our get hired live stream event on
tuesday april 27th
is for you this one night event
is going to help you learn how to get
clear on what you do best
get qualified for the job you want and
then get connected
to real job opportunities it's time to
take the next step toward the work
you love no matter your situation
ken coleman is going to be holding this
our
in-house career expert host of the ken
coleman show
and ken can show you exactly
what to do to land into a position
that is more fulfilling making more
money
and get your life back life is too short
now sometimes we go through dry seasons
sometimes we go through ups or downs
that's not what we're talking about but
if you're stuck in a mess
you're going to stay stuck there until
you do something about it ken can help
you do that
he'll give you an exact game plan step
by step
join him on tuesday april 27th to take
control of your career
and start working toward what you were
born to do
tickets start at just 20 text hired to
33789 hired
to 33 7
89. corey is in huntsville hi corey
welcome to the ramsey show how can we
help
hey dave thanks for taking my call today
sure honored to talk to you both
you too um my question is i started the
handyman business
about two years ago on the side and i've
got a steady job
but i want to take the handyman business
full-time
and it's kind of taking off to the point
to where
i work 4 10s on my regular job and
my other two days a week i'm working in
the handyman business and it's getting
to where i can't
keep up hardly so i'm kind of stuck i
can't make
any more really than what i'm making now
on the handyman business
why until i dedicate more time to it why
can't you raise your prices
well i i guess i could i'm just i'm
trying to get my name out there more and
they're already too busy how much how
much are you making right now on the
handyman job
well last year i've cleared about 15
grand
and i've got a little nest egg put back
in my business and
i've got right now i got about 10 grand
worth of work
on the books as far as profit
what do you make in your full-time job
around 70.
and about how many hours a week
realistically are you working on the
handyman stuff
probably 20-25
okay so if you doubled your income from
15 to 30
by doubling your hours only
you're still going to be at half of what
you're making now if you quit and go
full time
yeah yeah how long have you been doing
it two years
oh yes ma'am your name's out there corey
you've not been doing this two months
your name's out there if you're if
you're gonna get this job to be
something you can do full-time
and even get close to what you're making
now you're gonna have to raise your
prices
do you see the math of that because even
like dave said even if you double the
hours
you're still at half of what you're
making so so raising your prices work a
50 hour a week for 30 000
a year uh yes sir well
15 is what you're making on a 25-hour
week on handyman isn't that what you
told me
yeah that was last year which i i mean
every year i've started getting busier
and busier this year it really took off
and i'm getting all this work right now
so what do you project if you just
keep it going like you're going right
now part time what do you project you
will make on your handyman business
in this calendar year profit
i think i could make 30 this year on the
side okay
then if you doubled that and worked 50
hours you could make
60. yeah yeah so you still need to raise
your prices
the other thing i want you to not be
afraid of corey is a lot of small
business owners especially when you're a
solopreneur you're doing this whole
thing yourself
there's a fear that if i raise my prices
people won't come to me
pricing cannot be your only value
proposition
they need to come to you because you're
good because you're reliable because you
do the work on time you actually tell
the truth
you tell the truth and then when you
raise your prices they'll pay more than
you think
because they want a good reliable
handyman that does good work and what's
interesting is you actually may get
customers that you're not getting right
now because you're so cheap
what price range home are you working in
on average
uh probably around two hundred two
hundred thousand
yeah you need to kick that up yeah i'm
trying to get my name out and more
uh you need to be working 750 000 a
million and a half homes in huntsville
alabama
and they will pay more because let me
just tell you the the luxury market
uh if you can give them reliability
uh integrity uh you show up on time you
do what you say you're going to do
and it's quick it's efficient they don't
you don't give them a bunch of hassle
they will pay you for that and they
don't mind you are not ripping them off
i am one of them okay the other thing
corey is the handyman business that is a
word of mouth marketing business
everyone talks about who did great work
at their house they will tell all their
friends
so in case for some reason they don't do
it on their own which they probably will
ask for it ask for referrals you finish
a job leave your business card thanks so
much if you know of anyone else that i
might be able to help
get them spreading the word for you
among their friends among their friends
and that will grow your business even
faster
with your price increase you'll see this
thing take off a lot faster than it
would otherwise
yeah the yoga class for the woman that
lives in the
uh million two house uh is full of
prospects
once you've taken care of once you've
taken care of her problem and her
husband didn't have to screw with it
you are a freaking hero dude every
person that's ever worked on our house
has been a referral i've never brought
someone that i just
as a random person it's always been
someone worked on someone else's the guy
that built our deck at our house
it was a friend that built a deck and
did a good job it's word of mouth
and by the way when you do a good job
and you charge fairly and you charge
what you say you were going to charge
and you do it on time and efficiently
um you will not be able to beat people
away from your door
because you don't have any competition
because most people doing what you're
doing
don't do a good job they don't follow up
they they don't finish on time
come in on the house dirty and by the
way they get referrals too wherever
they're
that same yoga class knows don't use
that that's right that's right
because she's gonna tell everybody
that's how it works this tribal
marketing
get in these tribes so i think you need
to raise your sights on the price range
of home you're serving
the the wealth of the client that way
price is less of an object
um let's work this a little bit more
let's get this to where when you double
your hours by quitting
that you uh are going to at least make
what you're making
uh if you can get the boat that close to
the dock then i'll make the jump
but right now you're gonna be swimming
because the boat's not close enough the
dock you're gonna hit the water dude
uh because you there's too much gap
between where you are and where you want
to be
and you're just you it's a wing and a
prayer and a wish that you're hoping
it's gonna get you there and it's not
and corey write this down run your
numbers through the end of the year
what do you need to make how many hours
you need to work how many clients do you
have at what
at what dollar project to know by this
goal by this time frame
i could quit and make the same minimum
you need to see it because otherwise
it's just going to feel like this season
is never ending you're tired
from working full-time in this side gig
it'll motivate you to stick with it for
this whole season
to build that business up enough on the
side where you can make that
next step not a terrifying leap that
stuff you know what goes with that
that's that's a really good suggestion
and what goes with that the number two
punch with that is
start studying what type of
work has the most margin i mean are you
doing some stuff that has no margin in
it and
you know so you just quit doing that
type of repair
this type of unless it's a long-term
client and you got to do it just as a
favor
to keep a long-term client busy but
figure out where you're making your
stinking money
you may be able to do x type of a
handyman job and make
three times as much per hour as you
could on y
just because what people are willing to
pay for x versus y
yeah and find out i mean while you're at
it you can find out where where are you
losing money someone comes in and go oh
while you're here change the wall okay
well that's gonna be extra
you know add-ons scope creep yeah
exactly and it's like you know
you have a menu of services but take
stuff off the menu
that's not selling well and doesn't have
margin and
that's a beautiful way to get after this
man you've got a great business for you
let's just fine tune it a little before
you make the leap
that's what we're trying to help you do
here great question sir
this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show christy
wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today juan and lindsay are
with us they are ready to do a debt-free
scream from denver colorado hey guys how
are you
dean good how are you better than i
deserve
welcome so good to have you how much
debt have you paid off
we've paid off seventy nine thousand
three hundred and fifty five dollars
eleven how long did this take
15 months wow you kept it and your range
of income during that time
we started off at 108 and we ended at 1
30.
good what do you guys do for a living
i'm a nurse
i order selector at a king super
warehouse great
very cool good for you guys you've been
working your butts off hadn't you
yes so what kind of debt was this 79 000
credit cards student loans car payments
and a medical ivf loan
wow tons of debt
so what happened 15 months ago that let
you on fire
i wanted to be a stay-at-home mom and i
couldn't i was looking at our budget i'm
like we make so much money
i can't do this so
we had heard about you and i that night
i was googling how to like get rid of
that and i signed up for fpu and it was
no turning back after that that's cool
so juan wait a minute she she walked in
and said i just signed us up for him
what are you doing
yeah so i kind of followed her her step
oh so you no no resistance you just went
along for the ride huh
yeah i mean i just got tired of uh you
know we'll pay off one credit card then
you know slowly we'll start using it oh
i'll start using it again and
next you know it's three four thousand
on that and
just got tired of that yeah you know
let's say
tonight in fpu i would i cut up 22
credit cards and that was a record for
our class wow
that's a lot yeah yeah yeah
so you guys were just kind of doing the
rat and the wheel thing just run run run
run run have a heart attack and die
right
yeah lindsay you bring up a good point
though when you said you wanted to be a
stay-at-home mom and you looked at how
much money you made
and you couldn't do it i think a lot of
people have that moment where they
realize we are making such good money
and we have nothing to show for it we're
making such good money and we can't
achieve our goals whatever that thing is
and you realize in that moment
something's got to change yes
and all while doing it i lost 30 pounds
on beans and rice diet
okay well there's that oh my gosh
well discipline begets discipline they
say that when you've got your act
together in one area of your life it
blends over into the other areas very
naturally is what i've always heard
and i think that's probably absolutely
right so
very very well done you guys what do you
tell people the secret to getting out of
debt is
the cash envelopes yeah
yeah budgeting
so you guys were working together in in
unity in lockstep as you went along then
yeah yeah way to go congratulations
how's it feel
so amazing it's still not real like i i
can't believe we're even talking to you
this is amazing
yeah so when did you pay off the last
debt
uh february february 20th oh just the
other day excellent
so when you paid off when you paid that
off when you look back at the list of
people you paid off
which one debt on that list you go
i hate you people i'm so glad you're
gone
i would have to say it was ivf medical
loan because we had calculated we
wouldn't pay off our daughter until she
was 15 years old
and she's four years old now and we paid
it off so i'm like never again
never again
and that's that's a whole different type
of loan because of how personal
that is that's your baby yeah
wow i told her if we don't pay you off
mija the bank's going to come and get
you
whoa you have to sit in the vault until
we get you paid off and then you can
put you on layaway yeah she's not up for
a repossession oh my gosh yeah i'm i'm
thinking she's probably going to tell
her counselor this story when she's
older oh my gosh that's that's traumatic
i love it you guys are fun well
congratulations
you guys we're so proud of you very very
well done you're rock stars
so will you ever go back in debt never
oh
not for anything no nothing big enough
22 cards are gone your wallet's a little
thinner now in the best way
other than those cash envelopes those
cards are gone
yeah yeah even with the cash envelopes
like i have my debit card but i never
use it
that's cool i like that
hardly ever use mine i've got a i i
carry a
a money clip with money in it and that's
my redneck
envelope i guess but um but uh you know
and so i still use i use a debit card at
the gas station and a few other places
but uh
lots of places i i actually i'm still
that weird dude that pays cash and
people are like
how do you make change again you know so
because nobody knows how anymore so well
way to go you guys we got a copy of
rachel cruz's book for you know yourself
know your money
her latest new york times bestseller and
uh help you out with that and so count
it down
juan and lindsay denver colorado 79
thousand dollars paid off in
15 months making 108 to 130 count it
down let's hear your debt-free scream
three two one
that's what it sounds like when you
finally get
free when you finally get free
that's a big deal open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five rodrigo uh
is writing in asking about business
boutique he says my wife and i are
opening a new hair salon it will have
eight
booths being rented out do we need to
have an llc
you know dave you and i have talked
about this before because i actually
came to you years ago when we were
starting business boutique of what are
the technicalities and really
the simplest way you explain it to me
which i thought was really helpful is
are you in a high liability business or
do you have a target on your back
you know do you have the the perceived
wealth or or
a lot of wealth where people would want
to sue you and if you don't then you're
probably fine to operate as a sole
proprietor
for those first years starting out until
you really get you know into the into
the millions and so i think that
you don't see a hair salon as a high
liability business if you're opening up
you know something like i use the
example of a
you know a horseback riding camp for
kids that's high liability you've got
unpredictable animals that type of thing
but a
a hair salon i don't think is what you
think yeah i mean you've got eight
booths uh one of those people could get
twisted up and decide to try to sue you
or something so you could do an llc just
to kind of
ward them off because the most they
could get would be the the things that
the llc owns
if you lost the lawsuit yeah that kind
of a thing
um but uh you know good business
practices
more than anything else will keep you
out of court yeah and
um so i mean we've run this business for
30 years and i've had just a handful of
lawsuits out of all that time
of course the vast majority of that time
we have been an llc or a sub s corp
so it would be okay either way here
if you got eight people different people
at eight different booths that could
screw up
something yeah um i don't know what it
would be but people get pretty emotional
about their hair i hear i don't know
i don't have this issue but i've heard
that i've heard about stories so
people that have hair so uh but the uh
uh you know i mean if you got a i don't
know
uh uh someone felt like they got a
chemical infection yeah getting their
hair dyed or whatever i don't i don't
know i'm making up stuff here i don't
even
know but um um yeah the eight booths is
what
stood out to me as far as the only thing
that made me think it might need to be
but
typically i mean that's not a yeah if
you're not a dangerous business but if
you've got eight people that's just by
scale and scope
you know exactly and what you and i have
talked about in the past too is i
started this
as a sole proprietorship and you just
opened that as a dba doing business as
uh dave ramsey dba doing business as
the lampo group and then we incorporated
the lampo group and later took it to an
llc
but that was after we got a little bit
of size to where someone
there was something to get right but
basically if you're broke and you're
starting a business
and it's a little you know startup thing
you don't need to spend the money or the
screw with the tax returns do an llc on
everything you do
yeah that's overkill yeah this one's
kind of on the bubble so
wouldn't hurt to go ahead and do it just
because of the eight booth thing
that would be the only reason i would
think about it here but
good question riding in rodrigo we
appreciate that this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
christie wright ramsey personality is my
co-host
today open phones at 825-522
steven is in nashville hi stephen
welcome to the ramsay show how can we
help
hey dave hey uh christy huge fans of
what you are doing thanks for taking my
call
thank you sir yeah so
right now i'm in a pretty tough
situation i used to be in a band we
spent about four years building it and
eventually got offered a
record deal at the beginning of 2020 and
unfortunately
the lead singer in my band decided last
minute
that he didn't want me in the band and
cut me out of the record deal
and it's been a back and forth or deal
with our lawyers and their lawyers and
just trying to get what i deserve out of
it especially since i tracked on all the
previous songs that
were sold onto the label at this point
it doesn't look like they were going to
want to meet in the middle
and i don't have enough money to take
them to court so my question is
should i keep fighting for what's mine
or should i just let go of and trust god
with it
hmm so is there was there a partnership
agreement how was the ban
formed yeah so it was kind of
a it was just it was started off as a
thing formed in high school so there
wasn't really a
you know written agreement or anything
like that it just started off as a hobby
so but i mean what was your
understanding was you were a partner
yes sir that you were not an employee
right yes sir and was that everyone
else's understanding
yes sir what happened
like why did they kick you out do you
know what's the story
yeah so basically we had been in for
about four years
and when we were forming up getting to
the record deal
um basically all four of us there's four
band members and we had a new guy come
in
later on in the picture he wasn't an
original band member
and when he had joined uh
basically i guess he just started
manipulating i'm confused how
if your equal partners how one of the
equal partners can decide to kick
somebody out
yes exactly well why don't you just say
i'm not kicked out you are
[Laughter]
yeah well apparently the thing is he
already went behind
my back without telling me he went and
had another contract going and then
broke the news to me
what happened so i had there was no so
they did a contract
and everybody else signed it with the
record company and you you weren't
you were cut out of the deal that's what
it amounts to
right okay and that's how you kick you
out okay that's logical i'll see how
that happens
all right okay so what's on you is uh
and we've all done this but you were
young and stupid and you did not do
an agreement in writing and you don't do
anything in business without an
agreement in writing
and it's not because contracts are
magical make people behave
it's because that way there's a real
clear understanding of what the flip is
really going on here
instead we went from garage band and the
back of the van
into a deal with no agreement
and that's where you got screwed and and
so i've done stuff where i left myself
vulnerable
that's what you did and and i end up
getting screwed because i left myself
vulnerable and what i get from that i
call that stupid tax when i do it
because i pay i lose money because i was
stupid
and uh my trick is in life to never pay
the same stupid tax twice you won't ever
do this one again will you
no sir you'll always have it in writing
from now on
and so um how much money is involved
uh it was a six figure project so it's
250 000
project is that how much money you would
have gotten one-fourth or one-fifth of
that
um so there would be they didn't specify
exactly how much money up front that the
band members would get but about
90 percent of that 80 i'm guessing 80 to
90 percent of that was definitely used
for just marketing
studio fees okay so you didn't get it
you're getting real money
then so there's that's there's you know
you're gonna go to court over five
thousand bucks
gotcha i don't think it's worth the
headache stephen i mean
the money the money's a piece of it it's
more just like you just feel wronged
and i get that but you're continuing to
let it steal your peace of mind
by continuing to worry about it and so
it's just like dave said it's the stupid
tax i think you just cut your losses
walk away move on don't make that
mistake again
and i know you're on those tracks and
seeing them continue to make music
without you is like that's got to just
like
really get to you but i think if you can
let that go cut those ties and move on
you will feel such a different level of
peace because i just can't even imagine
how draining
this must be on you to worry about
stress about yeah
i mean they owe you for rent uh in your
head because they've been living in your
head for a while
yeah yeah absolutely that's what
christie's saying
and when you just when you give them the
eviction notice from your head then
you're going to get back to living life
again
and move on i i you know mathematically
it's not worth it to fight you're going
to spend 15
20 000 bucks trying to capture five
if you win and uh and i don't
it's not that there's not a principle
here that's worth fighting on
for me especially since you did not get
it in writing and that's on you as well
um and so i think you know i i think the
best thing that would end up happening
is you end up settling or some silly
thing like that
and it's some kind of a moral victory i
just i'm with you i think your first up
suggestion when you came on the
on the line stephen was do i walk away
and let god handle this and the answer
is yes
and that has nothing to do with them it
has nothing to do with what's right or
wrong
it has uh and it has nothing to do you
know there's some things worth fighting
for
um and you you know you allocate money
to fight for it
and it's just because i'm that's a fight
i need to win
just before the lord i'm not gonna get
messed over on this and i'm gonna fight
this one to the death
and so you know we're gonna just put a
budget together for the legal fees and
we're just gonna be there a while let's
just do it you know game on
uh but most things you're better off to
just go water off a duck's back and move
along
and um i mean this will be a less this
will be something you talk about with
buddies over coffee
20 years from now that happened to you
back when and it's just that time you
learned a lesson
i i would turn it loose um
and you know the other thing is is that
that you're in nashville
and the music business really is not
that big
and so now this guy every time you're
around
music this guy that screws people over
he's got another problem because he's
got you out here screwing up his
reputation
because it's screwed up because he lies
and steals
and so it's going to cost him a lot more
than five thousand dollars over the
scope of his life
because again you're in a fairly small
community of people they're not that
large
and so that you know they word gets out
on a guy
and nobody wants to work with him and
it's you know that
that that's gonna cost him he he's the
one that's really screwed up here
so anyway that that and the other thing
is you just learned america about record
contracts
woohoo we got signed we're going to give
you 250 000
except we're really not we're just going
to commit to spend that on you
sorta maybe and we're going to run up
the studio fees and we're going to run
up the recording costs and when all this
is done
you're going to get three dollars and
we're going to own your masters
and uh then if you get a big hit and
it's so big that it out earns all this
stupidity
then actually you will be a star and
have some money but most of the time
you will just end up with no money and a
record
the other thing stephen i just want to
encourage you is it it feels like that
maybe
you you're thinking if you decide to
move on and let this go that it makes
what they did okay and it doesn't
yeah it doesn't make it okay you're just
gonna move on
for your own peace of mind for your own
quality of life for your own progress
and not letting it continue to eat at
you so don't feel like it
somehow dismisses that this was a big
deal it was a big deal
and that hurt and those are your friends
from high school and that was your music
and your art you made together that
that must really hurt and it's okay to
be hurt and still decide to let it go
and move on
agree yeah i mean there are things that
hurt you and piss you off and you
remember them
and uh you remember the people and you
know some of these things
you know it's not a matter of sitting
around holding a grudge and you know
wringing your hands over it but but it
is to
you know if dr john deloney would hear
was there he would say you know
it's a loss and it's a valid loss and
grieving about a valid loss of
friendship
grieving about a valid loss of being you
know taken to the cleaners by somebody
is um
that's a valid thing you know you got
hurt dude and to christy's point i agree
with that
so but if i'm in your shoes you asked uh
i'd move on i pick my battles there's
some of my fight to the death but
most of them i don't so there you go
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money
and a career you are the hero in your
story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice kristy
wright ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host
today as we take your calls about your
life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
two carrie is with us to start off this
hour in detroit michigan hi carrie how
are you
hi dave how are you guys doing today
better than we deserve what's up
so i left my corporate job at the
end of february and i finished up
a certification that i've been working
on for about a year and a half
in animal training at the end of march
i've been working since the end of
february
on building website ordering business
cards
networking but i'm at a point now
where i'm i guess i'm nervous
to pull a trigger and publish
my website and distribute my
business cards at local businesses
and i guess i'm i'm nervous i'm guess
i'm looking for some advice on just how
to not
feel like a fraud since i'm still
new at this and how do i even go about
setting my prices
when i'm still learning
i'm i'm still you know a novice
um not a quote unquote
expert yet yeah carrie i'm gonna tell
you
the number one way to get rid of this
feeling
of the fear the insecurity the doubt the
imposter syndrome
all that the number one thing is to
start doing stuff
no no no listen i know that sounds
simple but here there's actually
there's a practical implication of this
okay i tell people all the time
the antidote to fear is action nothing
will
silence your fear of doing the thing
like doing the thing so go do the thing
nothing will silence your fear of
publishing the website like pressing
publish or taking your business cards to
the local
you know vets or wherever you're you
know
the action steps that you take
and every time that you take a step of
faith that you take a step of action you
actually start to do stuff with this
business
your fear lessons that voice in your
head gets quieter
your confidence grows and you go oh my
gosh i did it and i survived what else
can i do
but if you're waiting around until this
feeling of ready comes over you
it will never happen so like obedience
training for dogs
um actually i'm going to be working with
exotic birds
who who's your market what are you
what problem are you birds but you're
teaching exotic birds to behave
i am i am teaching exotic birds how to
behave and surprisingly there is a
market for it
and surprisingly you can do that that's
amazing that's the surprising part
so um yes so i'll be training
like parrots mainly um
parrots are one of the most re-homed
animals
um because they won't behave because
they won't behave they're
not meant to be in homes they're meant
to be in the wild
they're not domesticated so they get
mean
they're mean they're destructive and you
train them to not be so mean
instead of putting them on the grill
people re-home them okay
yeah have you checked out the market in
detroit
like is there like do you know the
market like where the parrot owners
hang out in detroit i do so when i left
my corporate job i took a job
in a exotic bird store basically just
doing retail sales which is horrible
but it's giving me the
opportunity to network with bird owners
i've also been networking with local
bird rescues
um to so
are you afraid that you cannot train
them
i've i've i have had some experience
but i i haven't experienced every issue
yet
you know and i i haven't i've been doing
this 30 years and i
this is the first parrot called we've
never so i've never experienced this
issue before but i'm winging my way
through it no pun intended
but uh all right all right here's the
thing
here's the thing so the only thing i can
draw parallel on
is i was with a guy who's been as a
professional dog trainer for hunting
dogs uh back last fall we had this long
talk about hunting dogs
just because i was interested in what he
was doing and what he was selling them
for unbelievable money
because he's apparently very very big
and he had this one dog he got
uh he could not train it he said i've
been doing this 20 years and he said
this dog
was an absolute butthole you could not
train this dog
and he said so i just sent it back to
the owner and i didn't charge him
because i couldn't help him
right so what's wrong with that strategy
no that's a good strategy you can that's
that is that is going to be a part of
the journey carrie i don't think you
need to dread that and fear that i think
you need to accept that
there's going to be there's going to be
a bird
i lived on a farm i had a horse back
years ago and i
same situation sent this horse to be
trained and they brought it back to me
they said we can't we've broken a
bazillion horses we can't break this
horse
i ended up selling the horse i couldn't
he couldn't be trained so
that's going to happen you just accept
that rather than fear it just accept it
but know that
the majority of the time you're going to
have
parrots that you can train based on your
education
and certification and you're gonna be
able to help these people but here's
what i want you to do i got a challenge
for you
i want you to get one customer i don't
care who i don't care where and i don't
care what you charge
you get one customer tell them you're my
first customer i'm gonna do it for three
dollars
but go do it for god's sake do it and
when you do it's going to do so much for
your confidence yeah yeah just get out
there and start swinging you know get in
the place swing the bat
don't wait until you're not scared to do
the thing you want to do do it scared
the antidote to fear
is action the first time i sat down in
this chair and
got in front of the microphone i
couldn't hardly talk i was so nervous
and now my pulse rate doesn't even
change you know but there are people
that walk up in front of an audience and
break out and sweat
do it scared play scared the first time
you got on stage i was there you were
scared i used this example all the time
because i think sometimes we look at
people doing things that seem scary and
we think oh well they're fearless
they're just confident they just have
this certain gene that i don't have
they're doing it despite their fear and
so carrie
if you're waiting for permission for
someone to give you enough approval or
someone to
tell you you're it's not going to happen
i need you to go get a customer any
customer
anywhere for any amount of money any
parent
and help this person with their parent
this week and watch how that first
customer that first interaction
do it scared will build your confidence
we work with dysfunctional parrots oh my
gosh this is so awesome but i love that
she said what if i get a pair of shoes
jokes we've never we've never got a call
on parrots before this is this is going
to be part of the journey
she could use she's just got to you got
to embrace the humor in this i'm going
to wing it yeah i can't help you this
one's a bird brain i mean you know this
is just so
you got to wing it this one's a bird
brain i couldn't help it you shouldn't
stay on
chapter two carrie read chapter two on
fear you got this for any of you out
there that are unemployed
shut up i mean she's a parrot trainer my
god
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
chrissy wright ramsey personality is my
co-host today
you and i have the blessing
of getting to teach people about
business about
money about life and
in a sense that's passing on a blessing
that that all of us have had at one time
or another and that is i think most of
us can look back
the vast majority of us can look back
and say somewhere
in our education career
k through college there was a teacher
that was a life changer i bet you're
seeing one right now in your mind
you know it's so interesting because
just the other day i was thinking of my
track coach but even with um
with writing specifically you know for
years dave i thought oh i'm not a writer
i'm not a writer
and i am a writer and i've gotten better
through practice but i remember even in
high school a specific english teacher
that just that one class and it wasn't
the assignments it wasn't the projects
it was how
she spoke life over me it was how she
believed in me how she encouraged
me in my writing projects that really
started that love of writing
for me at such an early age and it's
amazing how a teacher's presence and
and their encouragement can make a
bigger difference than even
what the subject is just the just who
they are in these kids lives
yeah i was scheduled to flunk the second
grade because i couldn't read
and um apparently my mother called a g8
summit in the principal's office and
they promoted me beyond my ability
anyway
and so i go into the third grade reading
below kindergarten level basically miss
mary jane hurt taught me how to read
wow and i've had seven new york times
bestsellers
wow i mean these teachers change the
whole trajectory of your life
that's right you know i mean these
teachers that don't mail it in now we
all had the one that mailed it in right
or the seven that mailed it in or
whatever including the tenured college
professor who didn't do a day of work in
their dadgum life after they got tenured
we got those too
but the the real teachers the ones that
see this as a
calling not just collecting a check
right
um they're the ones that change people's
lives and so
past years been pretty stressful we've
all gotten a new appreciation for our
teachers and that's why our team is
celebrating them with and
all of the hard work and dedication that
they give every day with our teacher
appreciation giveaway sponsored by
mobile the affordable premium wireless
provider don't miss out on the chance to
win
awesome cash prizes like the grand prize
five
thousand dollars cash for a teacher
so teachers here's what you do you don't
want to miss out on this go to
ramseysolutions.com
teacher and enter and you'll be in the
drawing
it is that simple you don't even have to
write an essay
we should do that just to be mean but no
just if you're a teacher
enter at ramseysolutions.com
teacher and we're going to give away
lots of cashes and lots of prizes but
the grand prize
five thousand dollars cash we used to
give away vacations back when people
could do those
but now you don't even know how that
works so we're just gonna give you the
money and you can figure it out
the giveaway ends on april the 30th just
around the corner
and if you're not a teacher be sure and
tell the teachers in your life or in
your kid's life
to go to ramseysolutions.com teacher to
enter
and uh speaking of great teachers we
have
rod haynes on the line rod is a middle
school teacher
in atlanta georgia at cruise middle
school and he teaches
our high school curriculum foundations
and personal finance our middle school
curriculum
for middle schoolers hey rod how are you
great dave thank you so much you and
christy i appreciate you guys having me
online
well thank you and we appreciate you
being one of those teachers that changes
lives and
teaching middle schoolers this stuff uh
so uh how many students at cruise middle
school
about 1300. oh wow it's a big school
school yeah
okay and uh how long you've been
teaching well i'm
finished up my 30th year um so yeah
congratulations wow that's nice congrats
and so you're teaching foundations how
long have you been teaching the uh
the curriculum to the middle schoolers
well thankfully uh
one of your smart invest investors got
involved in my life and
so thankful for roger s green and the
work that they do as a smart investor
and they have sponsored my class for
three straight years
over 300 kids for three straight so
we're looking at almost a thousand
students that roger
green has sponsored so yeah it's been
great wow that's amazing
we have a lot of businesses particularly
small businesses sponsor pay for the
curriculum
for a school middle school for high
schools all over america about 48
percent of the high schools have now
taught foundations and personal finance
the middle schools are catching on to it
we've got a middle school curriculum
that's highly popular
as well so i'm interested what are these
middle schoolers picking up out of this
that that
catches your eye and you go oh this is
worth doing
well it is absolutely amazing you would
be shocked at what they would say
i even pulled up a quote or two and i
thought oh my word i love what this one
sixth grade girl wrote she said uh
because we we do a ceremony at the
very end of the uh the unit when we
finished the foundation
and i asked them i said i need a quote
from everybody i want to know what
have you learned and this one girl just
summed it all up to me she said i have
learned
to never spend what you don't have
i love that wow she gets it i know
that's awesome
we need to elect her to congress oh so
true
wow that's amazing that's so fun how
rewarding is that that's so cool very
well you talked about a blessing
what a blessing it is to work with kids
to be able to
turn on light bulbs and to be but as you
said you know uh we have the choice to
speak
life into these children's lives so it's
a great blessing as you said it's a
calling and it's so much fun
um i hope i can hold on for several more
years because this this truth
has got to get out to our youth that's
awesome
you know one of the things we've seen
right is a lot of times when when kids
are learning this
in the schools they take this
information home and
start talking to their parents about it
they ask questions to their parents
about some of these subjects are you
seeing that happen to you
constantly so anytime i ge i get a
chance to connect with that child uh
parent through
either it's usually through an email
they will email me back and say oh my
word the conversations we've had about
the stocks
and about gamestop and had a great
conversation about long-term investing
versus what the craziness
of gamestop and had that con the kids
are going home
even today i finished up a unit on
insurance so i'm expecting
parents to get bombarded with these
insurance questions sue but i
always hear from these parents oh mr
ames thank you so much
for sharing it's opened up a line of
communication that
i actually didn't have with my middle
school child i don't even know
you know sometimes the parents don't
even know how to talk to their middle
school kids because they go into this
crazy stage but yeah it's a great
conversations happening at home that's
cool
that's really interesting yeah it's a
con it's a common language for
uh this age group that uh starts to act
like they came from another planet for a
little while
yeah that's a neat that's very cool and
thought about that
very interesting well well done sir we
appreciate you
teaching the class and we appreciate you
being one of those
teachers out there that uh that that is
changing people's lives
and uh we appreciate the folks over
green financial for sponsoring them
and uh putting the middle school of the
high school in there if you're
interested in helping us sponsor this
into your school
in your area you can take on a school or
you can take on a whole city
uh we've got national sponsors we've got
all kinds of things just get in touch
with our education solutions team at
ramseysolutions.com and click on the
education section and
we've got high school curriculum middle
school curriculum we've got stuff going
on in colleges and universities we've
got all kinds of different ways that
we're serving the students out there and
making it really easy for the teachers
to teach
material that is common sense and
staying out of debt
living on a budget the same stuff we
teach you guys and how many times have
you guys out there said i
where when we taught this stuff in colla
in high school it's basic common sense
why weren't we taught this in school
well it is it's taught in half the
schools and the other half need it
yep so it's that simple and remind
everybody to go to ramseysolutions.com
teacher and have all these teachers sign
up for this giveaway
that we're doing that ends in about a
week and a half on april the 30th
coming up really fast about two weeks i
guess and so
jump in and get that done here during
financial literacy
month so good stuff again rod hames in
atlanta georgia at cruise middle school
thank you
sir for your 30 years of service
yeah to those students and uh you're
incredible sir
and thank you for teaching our
curriculum we appreciate it
and we're honored to be partnering with
men like that and women like that
all over the america good stuff this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt
free stage tyler and
haley are with us christy wright ramsey
personality is my co-host today
if they're on the debt-free stage
christie that means one thing free
i'm so excited i love it how much of you
guys paid off uh
63 000 good for you and how long did
that take
about three years good for you and your
range of income during that three years
about 50 000 okay cool what do you all
do for a living
i am an advisor for transport enterprise
leasing
and i am a teller but i wasn't working
when we paid off the debt
okay wow good for you well
congratulations you guys
where do you all live we live in wringle
georgia it's about 15
20 minutes from chattanooga tennessee
yep just over the line
well good for you so 63
000 that's a lot what was it what kind
of debt was it
we had student loans medical debt
credit cards appliances cars and hbac
a little bit of everything you're kind
of normal yeah
normal but normal sucks yes
so you don't want to be normal anymore
what happened and woke you up three
years ago what put you on this journey
well we kind of started before three
years ago but it was a little
on the wagon off the wagon but
three years ago we just kind of said we
don't want to have debt we've seen
you know friends and family have debt
and we don't want to get older and still
have that debt
so we want to get rid of it while we can
okay so that
what do you remember what happened
exactly that said okay that's it we're
doing this
game on no falling off the wagon no run
along beside the wagon
riding the thing we had started
discussing the fact that we were going
to have children soon and we said
we definitely don't want to have debt
before we have children
yeah okay that's it gives you a
different perspective when you're
thinking about a family yeah
yeah you got to go well i'm going to
have to get my act together to be able
to do
this yeah okay good for you cool so what
were the first steps what did you do
once you said all right
in order to have babies we gotta get our
we gotta start acting like grown-ups and
we gotta get this mess cleaned up what'd
you do
we did the envelope system we started
with the envelope system
and sat down and wrote an actual budget
rather than saying
well we'll do this much on this and this
much we actually sat down
said this is what we bring in this is
what we're going to do for our groceries
our gas
everything so definitely making a budget
and doing the envelope system
yeah and sold our car and you sold a car
we paid a thousand to sell that car
we paid yeah we actually under it we
still owed money on it
and we said we don't want a car payment
and so we took it to carmax
and got rid of the debt we actually paid
a little bit to get out of debt but
what did you sell it for how much um
they paid
what like nine it was like nine thousand
and something and we owed like
about ten yeah okay good so that got rid
of
nine thousand of the sixty-three uh give
her ten thousand and sixty-three
actually but uh so very cool and then
that kind of broke things loose and here
we go
mm-hmm have you been a one-car family
during this time then no we actually so
we had a car um we had a car that was
already paid for
and then we had a little bit saved up
and so we paid cash for him
a car to just drive back and forth to
work
so then we had two cars again but we
just had one that we paid cash for
okay so you got got a little hoopty then
mm-hmm yeah cool it's a good deal so we
made that thousand back
yeah i love it yeah that's saved you a
bunch
good run good run what do you tell
people the key to getting out of that is
making a budget and working together i
mean if we weren't on the same page then
it definitely
wasn't going to work if he wasn't in on
it then it wasn't going to work which he
wasn't so in on it at first but
confession definitely working together
in a budget
sacrifice okay so how did you guys get
connected to us
i had heard of you through church but
really i kind of started getting
interested in finance when i
first or started my first job my nanny
had always told me
you saved your money and you tithe those
were my first two things she told me
as soon as i started my job and so i
kind of started researching like finance
and so i learned about you that way but
then also the financial peace university
um through our church which we actually
never took financial peace university
um but i had heard of it and then we
listened to your podcasts
a lot all right so tyler what got you on
board
tired of being broke 100 i know but
that's why i got you started
when she started she kind of started
then you came along a little later right
right there was a point where for me i
mean
just embarrassingly enough i couldn't
afford cheese for a party one day
so i was like something's got to change
i didn't know what it was
and then i heard about you through her
and then whenever uh
it was the interest part where i was
like well why should i not pay off the
higher interest first she's like
well because you're not gaining momentum
and that made sense what i'm doing
wasn't working
so i you know it didn't take much to get
me on board because i just didn't want
to be broke but
once we started going it started to make
a lot more sense very cool and loved it
too
that's awesome what was the what was the
part that now that you've actually
gotten to experience keeping your money
how does that feel to get paid and you
get to keep your money it's not going
out the window to all these debts how
does that feel
freeing i don't have as much anxiety and
stress
and just knowing that i mean not that we
can just do
whatever we want but we have a lot more
freedom than we had before
for sure absolutely well done you guys
i'm proud of you
thank you excellent excellent job well
we've got a copy of rachel cruz's book
for you know yourself know your money
her latest new york times best seller as
a gift
thank you for coming all the way to
nashville to do your debt-free scream
and i would like to throw in one thing
in there
during that time we probably would have
paid off a little bit faster but during
that time
we did switch to i quit my job so we had
two incomes and went down to one income
which
it did stay the same because he got he
made more
but i did get to stay at home with our
son during that and i finished my
bachelor's degree during all of them
good for you what's your degree in um
organizational leadership
oh very good good for you well well done
you guys
again proud of you that's that's quite
an accomplishment thank you all of that
done
in three years all right it's tyler and
hayley from the chattanooga ringgold
georgia area
63 000 paid off in three years making 50
000
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
[Applause]
wow very well done you guys
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure or you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping
new promos all the time always use the
promo code ramsey
today's question comes from john in
texas should i sacrifice time with my
kids in order to get a second job
as bad as i want to be out of debt i do
not want to miss my kids activities to
do so
i want to answer this as you are you
ready okay
is that what you would say would you say
boohoo get a second job
i mean here's the thing it's temporary
right like it's temporary sacrifice for
a long-term
reward take the second job you're not
missing everything you just might miss
more than you want to in this season to
get out of debt
was that was i right or wrong you're
right the vast majority of the folks
that get gazelle intense and they cut
everything out of their budget
and they're not going out to eat and
they're not going on vacation and
they're on beans and rice and rice and
beans
most of them are out of debt in 18 to 24
months
if you miss kids activities for 18 to 24
months
you are not going to change your life or
the kids lives
you're really not yeah i mean all you
have to do is think about a
military family where one of the spouses
is deployed
for six months to a year and they're
overseas somewhere
keeping keeping america free their
children
do not die from that uh they they
make it through it's um it is a an
emotional thing
uh and i missed some games but i missed
some games when i was starting this
business so that i never had to miss a
game again
and you can pick and choose what you
want to do yeah but
a lot of the kids activities and stuff i
mean
the kids don't even remember them yeah
much less remember
you know dad missed all my games when
you were four or your four-year-old
soccer league really
yeah i mean they don't even remember
yeah they don't even remember to kick
the ball at the gym
they're picking flowers yeah they're out
there wandering around singing
nursery rhymes i mean it's just i mean
it's i go
hey papa dave goes the games i see this
stuff i see what's going on i know
it's sweet that we can go there and be
there and you can pick and choose an
important item
right but but uh yeah it's worth the
sacrifice for a short period of time
would i do that as a way of life for a
decade not if i could help it i would
make some other changes
but i i think for a short period of time
you knock it out
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture today john 14 27 peace
i leave with you my peace i give to you
not as the world gives do i give to you
let not your hearts be troubled neither
let them be afraid
jesus's words sarah blakely says don't
be
intimidated by what you don't know that
can be your greatest strength
and will ensure that you do things
differently
from everyone else sarah blakely being
the
one of the youngest female billionaires
in u.s history
she invented uh spanx yes she did
and owns the company and spoke at our
entree leadership
summit a couple of years ago yeah uh
pretty impressive
very impressive uh young woman you know
what we uh
shared her story at business boutique
last year about how
when she was a child growing up around
the dinner table her dad would ask
the family how they'd failed that day
and they would celebrate that because
he he reframed failures if you're if
you're failing you're out there doing
stuff you're trying stuff
and so we did that in the room i had all
the women line up and just we had a mic
in the middle room and come
tell me when you failed or made a
mistake and everyone in the room cheered
and it just reframes for you that it's
okay if you mess up because you're
actually out there trying stuff most
people stay stuck on the couch they're
so scared
to make a mistake that they don't do
anything which by the way is a mistake
right right failure is a step what do
you use what's your quote uh
uh success is just a big pile of
failures you're standing on instead of
under yeah
it's a stepping stone on the way to
success you can't succeed unless you
fail along the way so i loved that
example of how her dad reframed that for
her
and she was willing to fail you know
because she was like i'm going to try
some stuff to get to where
i want to be and she sure did john
maxwell did a book a few years ago
called
failing forward yeah that that's the
only way you move forward is just
the trick is i mean what we're all
afraid of is not
failure we're afraid of fatal failure
and so i mean we're not suggesting you'd
be rash or gambling or
crazy or something like that so you you
pick your fight i mean you pick where
you're going
but if you you know a lot of the stuff
we're scared of
is more emotional than it is actually
for sure absolutely
but that keeps people stuck i mean
what's the worst that can happen
here you know and you feel if you'll get
that out and it's not death
right and it's not you know bankruptcy
you know
so you don't you don't try something
that you don't we don't want you to set
you up to where you try
things that cause you to fail file
bankruptcy that's not
or to die or something like that that's
not what we want to do but the
uh uh this idea that
you can do things without messing up is
impossible no one can do that well even
those
those fears of failure even the little
ones
keep people suck i hear is stuck i hear
women women say all the time
well you know what what if i launch a
blog and no one comes
what if i put this product out there and
no one likes it what if what if i
you know uh try this thing and it
doesn't work i'm like
okay but that's enough to keep them
stuck what will people think of me on
facebook what if she doesn't like
it's like you've got to be willing to
withstand that those
criticisms or rejection or mistakes or
failures or whatever
as a part of the journey of learning and
growing and trying more stuff because
it's amazing to me sometimes those small
things that you're saying
are enough to keep people stuck yeah and
here's the thing
um not what if i do this and they don't
like it
let me just tell you if you do it
somebody's not gonna like it
yeah just go ahead and accept it you're
gonna get a parrot you don't know what
to do with let's go ahead and accept it
on the front end
and move forward anyway instead of
fearing the possibilities like no just
know that it will happen
i mean it's uh uh like you know we put
these books on amazon and then people
rate them
and so i don't know what total money
makeovers got how many ratings on the
thing let me pull it up and look at it
it's hilarious so it's got a
uh what is this thing a 4.75 star rating
so that's pretty close to five right
right let's see here 20 000
people have rated the book and it's
rated 4.75 stars
okay so by definition
if you do an entry that's a one star
today having read that
documentation there you're what's known
as wrong
i love this example when you share that
and so it's just like you know it's so
true
20 000 people disagreed with you on
average
which means you're wrong right i mean so
why do people enter that but but i mean
but i can assure you
that in the last three weeks i don't go
back and look at them i mean it's just
i pull it up occasionally just because i
think it's an interesting study on
what drives people i'm also interested
in
in a weird sick kind of a way as to why
someone thinks i care
what they thought after 20 000 people
have already posted i mean i appreciate
you posting thank you for that but
but i mean it's just like truthfully
like i'm not gonna sell the book anymore
because you're pissed
right come on you think you're kidding
me really yeah so
uh what what drives this culture of of
people nowadays i don't
grasp it like i'm not going to stop so
we're not going to stop but here's the
thing
if you put it out there and that book
sold 8 million copies
and you've sold hundreds of thousands of
copies
of books you put it out there and you've
helped
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
of people with their businesses with
business boutique
and then somebody puts up a one star you
can count on
a hundred percent chance that
somebody is not gonna like your art
right somebody's gonna ship it anyway
right i'm not their style
one of the things that stuck out to me
this was years ago it was my very first
entre leadership event and i
spoke and i i watched the surveys
afterwards because it's my first event
on this stage
and of course like you know 98 99 were
positive there was like a one-star
review yeah you got one of the highest
ratings in the whole thing
they didn't yeah they but that but what
did i focus on i focused on
the one-on-one service critics math yes
so one of the things
98 times one percent equals zero yes
yeah and the thing that stuck out to me
is i had to remind myself
to put myself back on the stage to put
another book out there to continue to
put yourself out there is
i'm not fighting for them i'm not
fighting for the one star i'm not
fighting for the one star review the bad
survey
i'm fighting for the 99 that did get it
that i helped that that made a
difference in their
uh how they manage their time how they
manage their business whatever i'm
fighting for them so i'm going to
continue to walk on the stage put the
products out there and fight for the
people that i exist to serve
and be willing to understand one or two
or three percent may not get it and
that's okay i'm not fighting for them
it wasn't ever for them yeah that's okay
and you know
uh the point is let's see
oh i hate everything dave ramsey stands
for
well you never bought any of our stuff
anyway
when people are mean on social media i'm
like i'll give you writing a blog from
your mother's basement
i mean really i mean i'm sorry i missed
the part where you get a vote
so this is this is the thing and that's
what sarah's talking about there and
it's not to be
uh mean or sarcastic or something like
that or
uncaring or unwilling to accept input
right that's not the other you know
certainly we adjust our products we
adjust our
delivery speaking i mean if we crack a
joke on stage and it doesn't work
we don't use that joke again note to
self just we just took feedback those
crickets there crickets and so um
you know there's things you're gonna
you're gonna adjust things and you're
always gonna iterate up
but uh here's the thing
hear what christie's saying very loudly
if you are
not doing something because you think
someone won't like it
let me help you someone won't like it
do it anyway that's right that's right
you're not fighting for them
think of the ones you're fighting for
that your product is for that your
speech is for that your business is for
they need you
do it anyway yeah do it anyway and then
you celebrate your failures
because along the way about 90
of your great ideas that you have in the
morning while you're going for a run
you're in the shower you're doing
whatever and you have these great
entrepreneurial ideas about
90 of your ideas suck we have survived
90 of my ideas over 30 years here and 90
of our other team members ideas too
[Music]
uh of our money included we've made all
of our money
made all of our brand impact helped all
the millions of people we've helped off
about 10
of our ideas but all of them sound great
when you have them
sir sir so ship it as my friend our
friend seth godin says
ship it put it out there put yourself
out there
try it do something different and if you
don't do something different you're not
going to get a different result
try something new i mean you know this
whole get out of debt thing
go get yourself out of debt if you hate
it you can get back in
oh i miss those payments you can get
back in and you can get right back in
if you feel like you goofed up and i
missed those bills there was a stupid
thing going around on some of the uh
internet this guy you know i'm a 29 year
old millionaire and the worst thing i
ever did is pay off my house
well then go get a mortgage why get an
article about it just go get a mortgage
if you're so that gun brilliant
that's just ridiculous you know so yeah
you can undo most things
well that puts this hour of the ramsey
show in the books we will be back with
you before you know it in the meantime
remember
there is ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
you